foreign
it is one of America's most popular
endurance challenges each year more
than 3 million people visit part of the
Appalachian Trail but only a fraction about 3
000 people complete the entire 2200 mile
mountainous Trek Janet shamlin has the
story of how a mother and daughter
were inspired to conquer that roots
travel partner backed out of hiking the
Appalachian Trail her 66 year old mother
Susan stepped in the mom-ness in her kicked in
and she didn't want me to be alone and she was
a little bit scared when you volunteered to go
along with your daughter did you have any idea
everything that was involved no totally clueless
I just like I know where Maine is and I know where
Georgia is and I knew it was a long way but I
had no idea it was like climbing up and down
mountains the whole way was it ever this cold
on the trail Yes actually both women are active
having on marathons and other races but they
say nothing prepares you for the Appalachian
Trail you have to develop your Trail legs you
can train all you want before you get on trail
but you're not really training your body like you
do need to use your body on trail good morning
States almost 2200 Miles when she suggested hey
I'll do it with you any trepidation on you oh yes
100 she has got to be the most accident-prone
person on this planet so I was worried for her
safety oh we made it to the ER and there were
mishaps mom fell and hit her head again second
fall what were your injuries I got 10 Staples
across the top of my head and I mean stitches
you're kind of used to but Staples you know
that was weird so that was in rock Sylvania
rocksylvania is what they call the state of
Pennsylvania because there is a very significant
portion of the trail that is made up of rocks but
the team resilient Go Mama the thought of giving
up never entered my head the trip had a greater
purpose fundraising for Parkinson's in honor of
Greta's father and Susan's husband Ron who has the
disease I think part of it that really helped with
that was the bigger goal you know finish the trail
raise money for Parkinson's research so without
those kind of it would have been pretty easy to to
give up and go home they've raised eighty thousand
dollars but but as meaningful was what others did
for them what did you take away from this just
the kindness that is alive in humanity people
are so kind and we stayed in the homes of 25
different people who we had not met before doing
the trial in our world we just hear so much about
the negativity or the bad things that are going
on and the trail really opened our eyes to the
goodness that is alive and we've heard the phrase
if you want to restore your faith in humanity go
hike the Appalachian Trail because boy oh boy is
that true it's such a great experience I mean we
feel so blessed to have had the opportunity
and the joy of this reunion it Trails End
the man in their heart every step of the way for
CBS Saturday morning Janet shamlian Minneapolis
that was so special I love every bit of their
story and what they learned and they stayed in
25 different people's homes I know who didn't
even know them have you ever backpacked over
a period of time with people it's it's that
kind of you meet people in that restorative
sense of humanity comes back to you they
just do you and I both have the both eighty
thousand that's a lot of money raised a
lot of money you're here good for them